Granato lies at the foot of the Sierra
Nevada mountains and only 70 kilometers
from the Mediterranean coast
it's home to 240,000 people tatiana
Garrido is a professional flamenco
dancer and a native of the city
Zak Atene is the main shopping street in
Granada nearby is the big Rambla square
the names harken back to a time when
Granada was ruled by the Moors
rereading it another so local living
here is a luxury because you've got the
Sun the beach and the mountains
it's a typical Andalucian city it's a
center of flamenco and because I'm a
flamenco dancer I am proud to live here
the former Arab bazaar the Alcazar ayah
is the place to go for souvenirs
Christians Muslims and Jews shape the
history of the city it was also a blend
of different cultural influences that
shaped Andalusia and signature music and
dance tatiana Garrido's family have a
strong tradition of flamenco
I mean even before money remain Co is a
way of life for me I've been dancing it
since I was small it's a very lively art
very strong with lots of energy and I
think we and illusions are like that
we're full of life and passion and
that's expressed in flamenco si se
petitioner flamenco forcibly focusing in
1492 Granada was the last of the Arab
states of al-andalus to fall to
Christian forces the cathedral is a
symbol of the reconquest but Granada's
most famous building dates back to the
time of the Arab Almohad dynasty they al
hombro every year the complex with its
famous fountains attracts some 2 million
visitors
it's a unesco world heritage site and
one of the most stunning examples of
Islamic architecture in the world the
architecture we have in Granada is
something unique and magical it's
described in Arab literature such as the
Arabian Nights the architecture is so
fascinating because it's so delicate
inside the fortress yet appears so
powerful from the outside
Danijela grammatical is Italian but it's
been living in Grenada for 19 years
he knows the old Arab quarter the Albay
scene inside out losing your way in the
labyrinthine alleyways of the old city
is a joy one typical feature of the area
are the car - luscious walled gardens
belonging to villas these streets could
be in North Africa Daniel takes a
timeout in the tea shop scene the
fingerprints of the past are visible in
the eye by scene structure of the old
town and the layout of the streets is
still there you feel like you're in the
casbah a medieval settlement surrounded
by walls because from that fort if you
got a typical mediaeval in another
corner of the city Tatiana meets up with
her friends in a tapas bar tapas are
small snacks ranging from chorizo
sausage to manche goat cheese they're
often served free with drinks a custom
that was once common throughout Spain
we and illusions are pretty easygoing we
like to get together whenever we can
have a beer and enjoy the moment and
revel in a little flamenco
the iconic Andalusia dance is known for
its emotional intensity expressive arm
movements and rhythmic stamping of the
feet flamenco is performed and admired
around the world but the sunset here in
Granada is unique and you can enjoy it
in any way you want
you